hello welcome to the debate on Sky News
I'm Martin Stanford here's our take on
developments brought together from
America the UK and around the world will
take nothing and no one for granted I
will run with heart and I will run to
win America can't succeed unless you
succeed that is why I am running for
president of the United I am officially
running for president of the United
States
and we are both
our country great again decided yet or
is there too much choice why the
fighters of religious wars don't take
religious holidays and love and Lego for
the ten-year-old boy with no friends the
candidates are stacking up to live at
1600 Pennsylvania Avenue at least a
dozen Republicans and a handful of
Democrats have made thee that is why I
am running speech is there too much
choice causing voter confusion in a
moment we speak to match slab who's
chairman of the America Conservative
Union but as usual the Democrat
commentator Geoffrey Robinson is
standing by for us in New York and
conservative commentator Armstrong
Williams is in Washington Jeffrey too
many candidates or is it good to have a
lively field no there's really only one
candidate and that's Hillary Clinton all
the rest sir are pretenders to the
throne mostly drivers of the clown car
and a few fairly serious relatively
serious people on the Republican side
none of whom were going to beat Hillary
and you look at Jeb the country said
really had more than enough of the Bush
family thank you very much eight years
of W probably has poisoned the well for
Jeb I was just in Florida on a speaking
tour and the feeling in Florida is the
Jeb can't even win Florida he was the
governor down there but they hate him
the teachers the cops the firemen hate
him because he he backtracked on his
promises to them he sponsored something
called Common Core which was an
educational program that failed which is
the bane of the Republican Party the
Republicans hate common core and they're
not gonna nominate Jeb Bush he is he's
really out of step with most of the
Republican Party so you know what are
you left with ben Carson good luck no
it's Hillary all the way I'm strong I'm
sure you'll disagree with that and it's
your look if America's had enough of the
bushes what about enough of the Clintons
you know I've learned through experience
and wisdom to be very careful when
you're so emphatic about what's going to
happen in the future especially when
you're dealing
300 million people whose minds can
change we've never seen an election
cycle like the one we were seeing where
dark horses still seem to be lurking and
standing in the race and I would never
minimize the bushes RT Clinton's
contributions to this country and their
sacrifices obviously I'm sure Jeffrey
was certain that Hillary Clinton was a
shoo-in when she ran against this guy
with the name of Barack Hussein Obama
and nobody ever thought that any man
with a name such as that could ever win
the White House the American people are
willing to tell you they're willing to
listen to all these candidates whether
they come from a dynasty or whether they
come from poverty because they realize
the country is still in trouble poverty
still exists we still have these racial
wars that we see that continue in this
country people don't have the
opportunities they feel they deserve
they still want a piece of the American
dream I think this is a wide open
election I think it's anybody's to win I
don't think it's going to be enough to
have money I have the nice name of a
bush or Clinton I think you got to
really convince the American people that
you have the ideas you have the right
team you have the right organization to
move this country for and I tell you I
think we all may be surprised and
shocked who the next president of the
United States will be when they are
inaugurated in 2017 while also in
Washington first today is max lap who's
chairman of the American Conservative
Union and a former White House political
director to president george w bush so
he knows the political scene very well
the Donald Trump candidacy is an
interesting one isn't it because he will
have an impact on the campaign if he
doesn't make even if it doesn't make
progress in the campaign would you agree
yeah I think he shakes things up and I'm
glad that he's running as a Republican
quite frankly he speaks to a lot of
people in America who are fed up with
Barack Obama and his failed policies I
mean Hillary Clinton if she's this
leading candidate is going to have to
convince the American people that we
need a third Obama term the American
people have hardly ever given a third
straight term to a political party they
did to george HW bush in 1988 but he
didn't get reelected and i don't think
they're going to do that with hillary
clinton so people like Donald Trump
Donald Trump is a real cannon I'm glad
he's running I'm glad he's running as a
Republican
and he's going to give voice to these
people that say look we need to have
better wages when you have wages who are
that are rising we need to be able to
create more jobs we need to be able to
have cheap and and and and ready energy
and we need to make America great again
and by the way that also includes making
America great again overseas no offense
but a lot of Americans were offended
when Barack Obama went throughout Europe
and overseas and apologized for what
America had been doing over the course
of the last decade I for one think that
the American president and George W Bush
gave great leadership on the issues of
terrorism which the country is facing
and Tony Blair and others did as well so
this is a real important election for
America Donald Trump and the other
candidates who are running are giving
voice to these concerns and I'm glad we
have so many candidates running on the
Republican side when we get our nominee
he or she will be ready to win okay Matt
Jeffrey is almost crying within in
frustration back well I throw more one
question at you first of all if we may
during the Obama years isn't it fair to
say that the Republican Party always a
broad church has become even broader the
range of opinions under that Republican
label are as diverse as ever so can any
one candidate bring all those people
together yeah because here's where the
most dominant influence in our politics
right now is the feeling in this country
just look at the poll numbers this is
not match laps of pain you look at the
poll numbers Barack Obama is a failed
president and they look at his radical
policies even the Supreme Court is most
likely going to take is one achievement
Obamacare and get rid of it and the
American people look at what Barack
Obama has done to this country and they
wholesale II reject what he has done so
I think for the Republicans it's
actually an easier course than many
people realize yes we have to have
policies we stand for we have to have a
positive agenda but we have to remind
the American people that just because
Barack Obama was president which would
have been eight years doesn't mean that
we have to embrace that agenda and we
can be great again as Donald Trump said
yesterday in his in his announcement
Jeffrey don't put all your hair out but
just try not to some of the points if
you will I'm sorry max you're completely
delusional
like most conservatives in this country
you are wrong about everything not just
about everything but everything
completely everything if you think the
George w's presidency was valid and good
my god you've got to read history was
the most disastrous presidency in the
history of this country now let me say
something the fact is the Republicans
will do what the Republicans always do
they will implode they'll nominate some
clown it'll probably be rand paul
although it might be Walker from
Wisconsin l nominate some claret won't
be Jeb Bush because he can't get the
nomination and they will implode I mean
the Romney campaign what a joke that was
seriously Hillary's going to win it and
win it big time because the Republicans
are now a party of the South a white
party of the South they have excluded
young people have excluded old people
they've got voter restrictions they're
trying to push through they've spent
most of Barack Obama's presidency trying
to undo his presidency they haven't
passed a single piece of worthwhile
legislation when they had the chance I'm
just baffled listening to Jeffrey and
what he's espousing the fact that he
actually believed that nonsense most of
it that he just stated he is so blind in
his dislike his distrust and
unwillingness to see the failed policies
of the president whether its foreign
policy whether it's a right whether it's
a real Israel whether it's Iran well
there's Libya whether Syria just because
these these countries are not on the
front pages of the papers and on
broadcast TV doesn't mean they're still
in chaos even though Affordable Care the
Supreme Court is about to make a rule
yes President Obama's policies have
failed and the president is not
dependent on the Republicans to get a
trade bill the bottom line is that if he
thinks that Hillary Clinton is a shoo-in
I gotta tell you I just hope he's not
advising her if she makes it she's going
to have to earn it she didn't get it the
first time around and I wouldn't be
surprised if she doesn't even get the
nomination yes you say whatever you want
to say about the Republicans but whether
you like it or not the Republicans have
galvanized they're moving legislation
through Congress and if you look at the
diverse of Caliphate candidates whether
it's Donald Trump or any of these other
candidates they're often rely deals
whether it's on immigration is about
strengthening ourselves on the world
stage how will we lead but let's talk
about these issues that the
entitlement programs are not working
that you got to give people opportunity
you've got to make them believe in
themselves because the programs of the
50 50 years ago I destroyed them and
we've got to move to something else we
don't want to cut loose the safety net
we want people to be able to govern
their lives and govern their
opportunities because this is something
that the government has failed at the
other why you seem Ferguson that's why
you seem Baltimore and yes the
Republicans have the best opportunity of
taking back the White House in 2016
mashallah let me put to you this whole
question about Hillary because you
dismissed a rather as another Obama term
she has time if she Rises through the
ranks and gets the support over the next
year to characterize her own terms of
what a Clinton presidency would look
like does she has time on the side to do
that yeah look I want to give her her
due when she ran for president in 2008
she got much better as the campaign went
along by the end I think she was really
an effective candidate she just got
started so slowly and she had just a
horrible strategy including with her
budget and everything else so yeah i
think she'll get better and she'll find
her voice but she has to overcome this
fundamental question which is our the
american people ready to give the
presidency to someone that pretty much
has the same policies as Barack Obama
and I just really don't I think in all
honesty when you look at the polling and
everything else there it's going to be a
very tough case for her to make now does
she have an amazing personal story would
the American people like the idea of
having a first woman president all these
things are compelling and she'll make
those she'll make that case but at the
end of the day I think what Trump's that
is the fact that they simply want
leadership and confidence back in the
White House they haven't seen a lot of
confidence from Barack Obama and by the
way he was a rookie senator who we put
in to be the president with basically no
leadership skills they see how that has
worked out internationally and
domestically and they don't like it I
think they're going to give the Republic
that's the one you see you confuse
Hillary of having she's not naive she's
got experience in spades doesn't she she
has experience in spades but when you
look at the fact that the American
people want two things they want
leadership but they don't want the same
old same old right so they want somebody
outside of Washington and what Hilary
has brought to the table with all the
scandals on her face
foundation and all the fact that she's
been cheap potentially used the office
of Secretary of State to pad her
husband's pockets with money it brings
up all the things about the Clintons
that the American voter doesn't like
there are things they do like but the
things that they don't like is the fact
that they seem tawdry they seem gaudy
and quite frankly they think the rules
don't apply to them well let's just ask
jeffrey about that soon as you brought
up the subject how much i'd like that
please how much time does jay does
Hillary Clinton Jeffrey have to spend
defending the email trail or what she
was doing on our server or Benghazi and
all these other things which hover over
her right now well they hover over it
because the Republicans being so
delusional having absolutely nothing to
offer the American public have to go ad
hominem they've got to go after her
because they've got no other thing they
want to get rid of Obamacare they want
to bomb Iraq they want to do all the
crap that they usually want to do which
are failed policies of george w bush so
what do they do with Hillary who's got
ideas go after Hillary Benghazi has been
is rhetoric is over and over and over
again there's nothing there the email
situation is nothing there and by the
way for dead people the Mac oh crap by
the way we're dead people have you not
nothing you should take that back and
apologize it's the usual BS you it's fat
jet ambassadors it's rhetoric it's gar
fat the fact that you say that that she
lined her husband's pockets is probably
slander she didn't there's a foundation
involved it's not her husband's pocket
there's a foundation so you got to get
your facts right which have been wrong
during Bush administration and they're
wrong now I mean it is just so
unbelievable that you keep vomiting our
patient works you're a piece of work
it's garbage garbage under it you know I
inherited focus guys find a minute I
find it fascinating that Jeffrey we try
the brain her emails at the State
Department Benghazi the fact that yes
they believe in the law as long as it
doesn't apply to them the fact that most
Americans don't trust him the fact that
you can tie her meetings at the State
Department with the foundation and
giving the problem is if Hillary is
going to ever rise above this she's got
to face the fact that she has addressed
these issues and make sure that her
arrogance don't lead her to these kind
of issues
and bad judgment in the future if you
keep making excuses for her and blaming
the Republicans she will tank real fast
he has addressed this is Republican it
is he has it yes people are vomiting for
a neurologist and it enablers okay holy
guys for a second so I want to throw one
last one up Matt when this is it's this
for all the candidates Matt and a right
across the piste whoever they turn out
to be the old maxim about it's the
economy stupid does that not still apply
in 2016 own Obama may have done many
things but the economy is beginning to
tick up so I guess for his team things
are looking better now I think that's
untrue matter of fact if you look at the
polling the American people are very
disappointed in the one thing that the
Democrats always say is that we haven't
had real wage growth in this country
it's one of the biggest and most
important issues and we've actually seen
that be even a bigger problem under
President Obama's economy and if you
look at all the all the statistics on
the poor and poverty in this country
they've all gotten worse under Obama so
the American people actually don't feel
very good about their economy but I do
disagree on whether or not this will be
a pocketbook election a lot of times our
presidential campaigns are a pocketbook
election I actually think in 2016 the
number one issue is going to be security
there's gonna be real questions over
crime in our communities but also what's
happening overseas with Isis and what's
happening with radical Islamic terrorism
and I think those issues are going to be
back to the forefront in politics and I
think that once again the Obama agenda
on those issues is paltry poor and the
American people want to change match
that we thank you for your time thank
you
a reminder you can catch up with the Sky
News debate on Apple TV Roku and on
catch up and of course on Sky News com /
us next what is it with the fighters of
religious wars their ideology is used
for war and yet important tenants are
ignored when the time comes for peace
the UN chief Ban ki-moon called for an
immediate humanitarian pause in Yemen to
mark Ramadan stressing that the holy
Muslim month should be a period for
harmony peace and reconciliation and
senior clerics appealed for a truce in
Afghanistan but both calls have been
rejected well haroon mogul is an Muslim
academic and an author he's also an avid
observer of developments in the Middle
East it doesn't all go well for this
season does it do you think Ramadan will
be more peaceful this year probably not
unfortunately I think you hit the nail
on the head the problem is that the
people who are asking for these things
completely get ignored and overlooked
nobody's really listening to them why is
that what they simply have when it comes
to military matters or territorial
matters I suppose they are they simply
have no influence unfortunately to a
large degree the old religious
establishment that used to dominate a
lot of communities is dying it's fading
away for four different reasons but the
conclusion is the same this this
religious establishment is losing its
clout and there are new voices and and
these voices tend to be a lot more
intemperate and a lot like a lot less
likely to listen to these kinds of calls
to reconciliation or peace or even a
temporary ceasefire and yet isn't there
an irony here because it's often in the
name of religion or because I belong to
a particular religion or faith that
people are fighting in the first place
yeah i mean i would go so far as to say
that that most of these groups aren't
are really deeply religious this is much
more to do with identity politics than
religion in a meaningful sense it's not
really Sunni or Shia because i'm i'm
really debating what to the Prophet
Muhammad mean by this or that it's
you're different from me and who's going
to get power and
how do I keep you from taking power over
me that's it well let's just bring in
Geoffrey Robinson in New York and
Armstrong Williams in Washington
Armstrong let me throw the point to you
is it the case that religion religious
leaders worldwide of whatever faith just
don't have the clout and the persuasion
they used to you know it is it's a
little deeper than there you know is one
thing when you say that you have that
your person of religion and when you say
that there are certain things that
people should expect from it equality
upliftment from poverty that their their
needs are met not a hundred percent
taken care of and that there is fairness
across the board and when you begin to
see that certain classes are protected
you begin to see the inconsistencies in
the law and how you wait your hand of
judgment and fairness and people can
change there's your spiral out of
control in poverty and their loved ones
then they begin to lose faith in the
religion they make religion synonymous
with the Creator and what we forget
sometimes is that men become greedy they
become grub corrupt they become selfish
and they don't serve the needs of the
poor of the downtrodden they serve their
own selfish needs to keep themselves in
power and they gained this power by
putting their feet on the poor and over
time people rebel and therefore they
have no respect for religion no respect
for people to call then they begin the
blame God and they begin to believe
there's no such thing as right and wrong
and in their world the only thing they
have is a gun chaos anger and rain and
terror on those communities and on those
state-run governments and so until
religion shows people that you can
uplift them and things are fair and
balanced these situations will change it
so it's ridiculous for them asking these
terrorists these people who are hurt and
angry oh that's have a two-week truce so
we can respect Ramadan and have peace
they think this is about as ignorant as
it sounds and said what respect what I
don't respect you so I'm going to
continue my bloodthirsty terror until I
get what we want and change this regime
and make it better for our suffering
people is it that clearly Jeffrey that
political leaders have lost their way
they have no inference religious leaders
have lost their way now have instance
one disperse who has influence over
anyone anymore well I mean the religious
leaders and the people who are talking
sense you're speaking in in I don't know
there's this speaking in tongues because
the people who got the guns and who were
beheading Westerners don't speak that
language Haruna's absolutely right its
identity politics and and Armstrong is
right that in the sense that religion is
has become a recruitment tool now I've
been wondering about something for quite
a while we look at the problems in that
part of the world through a tinted lens
of 911 we see everything in the context
of 911 and it's not right or wrong it's
it's just the way we see these things
and I wonder maybe her room can speak to
this if we look at all the problems in
the Islamic world through that tinted
lenses 911 it's possible that we will
not come to any valid conclusions or
solutions for what ten 15 20 years there
may not be a solution for that long
because it will take that long for us to
see things as they really are look in
the united states in the West we we tend
to forget that history works in cycles
that there or at least especially in the
United States I think we have a very
narrow view on history so we tend to
think that everything works in one
direction and once you set something up
it can't collapse or it can't fail or
that it'll simply pop back into
existence magically of its own accord
the Middle East right now to me looks a
lot like Europe on the eve of World War
one you had monarchies they were all
Christian countries that have
fundamentally very similar ideologies
and they marched hundreds of thousands
of young men to slaughter for years for
no apparent purpose the French the
Germans the the Russians the the English
the ideologies were not that different
and and yet the war wouldn't stop and
many people thought it would stop after
a few months so that it would be a brief
skirmish or that it couldn't spell out
of control and what I'm afraid of is
that that we're at that tipping point
that countries like Saudi Arabia on Iran
are in a proxy war and they don't really
there's no one to put the brakes on
there's no adults in the room and and as
was correctly said there's no one who's
going to be listened to so how do you
stop it from getting worse I don't
can I throw can I throw another thorny
issue into the debate here though that a
lot of the extrapolation from the
conflicts around the Middle East it he
said Israel Palestine if you if you
sorted out the Palestinian complaint
about their poor standard of living
their lack of territory and their
lifestyle that then crack that nut if I
could be so flippant about it and then
you may be stand a chance of sorting out
the rest of the Middle East is that too
simplistic Haroun well there's truth to
it but perhaps not in the way we think
if you look at the Palestinian situation
the fact that they're oppressed that
many of them are stateless that the
refugees and you've got hundreds of
millions people around them were
ostensibly sympathetic to them and yet
have never been able to do anything
meaningful and politically positive for
them I'm not talking about war violence
I'm just saying for example lobbying for
them or or offering sticks or carrots or
anything in the way of diplomatic
solution or resolution that's the
problem the problem is that people in
the Middle East rightly feel that their
governments their states are weak that
they don't protect them they don't
advocate for them they don't care for
them they don't improve their standards
of living and therefore you end up in a
situation where people have absolutely
no desire to listen to anything that
those governments say and actually want
to overthrow them whether peacefully or
violently or simply cynically check out
of politics altogether so Israel and
Palestine in a way is is an
encapsulation of a bigger problem not in
the simplistic sense that if there was a
Palestinian state all these problems
would go away of course they wouldn't
what's happening in Syria would not be
solved by a Palestinian state but it's
symptomatic of a deeper problem in a lot
of Middle Eastern countries which is
that right now they're not getting the
government's they deserve some of that
is due to foreign interference some of
that is due to domestic politics but the
reality is still the same that these are
countries with massive militaries under
developed economies and their primary
strength seems to be impressing their
own people and shooting up and when they
ask for anything better haroon mogul
thank you very much
well last year's Zakaria hymnals mum
arranged a 9th birthday party for him he
lives with autism and she asked if
everyone could bring a piece of Lego so
they could build something together but
no one turned up this year she took to
Facebook and has been completely
overwhelmed Geoffrey Robinson in New
York and Armstrong Williams in
Washington Armstrong the result was just
well if our last discussion made you
despair for the human race this one
makes you think there is some hope well
you know I think they're tied together
in some very interesting way even when
you cry for hope and you at your last
leg because we're talking about Lego but
it's obviously something the mother
could not afford but it's something she
wanted very badly for our autistic son
and then when none of the kids showed up
it had to be devastated and when she
lost everything she went to the people
where the compassion and the real help
can come from and the real sensitivity
because they can relate to it and it was
done they love was outpouring and and
sometimes in crisis situations when you
feel all is lost sometimes you have to
go to the very people who have far more
and far more compassion and you could
ever imagine even their I'm having less
and struggling like you they're willing
to take from their struggle they're
willing to deplete their resources to
make a child happy and bring joy to
their life so yes that is an example of
what we all need to realize that one of
the things that keeps countries and
other world governments from totally
collapsing is the goodness of the people
that exist it reminds us every day is
the little things that we do and we
forget about that can make the
difference in the lives just everyday
normal people and Jeffrey of course she
had some friends on Facebook that's what
it's there for but the point was this
story went massive didn't it and there
were people complete strangers who felt
they wanted to give the power of social
media to find a heart beating in the
inside people who are sometimes
described as heartless listen it's a
great story and the world needs more and
finally stories as their said in
newsrooms what are we close with will
find and finally there's this you know
we need more of these and finally
stories because they become the sweet
dessert after a meal of undigestible
horrific news it's a great story and
long may they wait I like that a sweet
dessert and a good spot to finish thank
you both very much indeed as always for
being with us this time and that is it
for this edition of the debate you can
continue watching sky news on apple TV
on roku and on ketchup and of course on
Sky News calm until next time goodbye